يجب أن يكون الفصل في جلسة الآن هنا في
هوساكا ، فقد أصبحت المدرسة ملجأ مؤقتًا
للنازحين في
فصل دراسي واحد قابلنا إبراهيم حسن
الأب الكردي لخمسة أطفال يخبرنا أنه
اضطر إلى الفرار من منزله في الأسد
مع أطفاله عندما كان التركية
بدأت العملية العسكرية ، وهذا ما
تبقى من منزله ،
ويقول إبراهيم إنه واحد من العديد في
حيه الكردي الذي تعرض
للنهب عمداً من قبل القوات المدعومة من تركيا
، أخذوا كل شيء ، وبعد
أن أخذوا جميع ممتلكاتنا أشعلوا
النار
فيه قبل أيام فقط.
بدأ الهجوم ، وكان أطفال إبراهيم قد وضعوا
صورهم مبتسمين مع القوات الأمريكية التي تقوم
بدوريات في
المنطقة ، ويقول إن وجود أمريكا منحه
إحساسًا زائفًا بالأمن وفجأة
ذهبوا منذ أن خانتنا أمريكا في
كل مرة أنظر فيها إلى هذه الصور
لأولادي تبدو الأمريكيين كما أريد.
لمحوها ، هل تشعر أنك تثق
في أن الأمريكيين لا يزالون يتمتعون بالمظهر
الأمريكي الصغير الذي نسمعه الآن ونراه على
تلفزيون أمريكا  بالقول إنهم
هنا فقط من أجل النفط ، فلماذا فعل ترامب
هذا ، لقد خانت كل الناس ، إنه
شعور وجدناه يتشاركه الكثيرون هنا ،
حيث نزح ما يقرب من 200000
شخص بسبب هجوم الديوك الرومية ،
وقد تضررت مئات منازلهم أو
نُهبت.  تحاول السلطات
الآن إخراجهم من المدارس حتى
يتمكن الطلاب من البدء من جديد وإلى
معسكرات مبنية على عجل مثل هذا ، الظروف
قاتمة والموارد شحيحة
بسبب الوضع الأمني الذي اض
رت وكالات الإغاثة الدولية إلى ال
نسحاب دون الاعتماد على أحد.  صعب فقط
هنا لأنه بارد جدًا
خاصة في الليل ، ليس لديهم
ما يكفي من الطعام وليس لديهم كهرباء
والمياه لا يقول منظمو المخيم أن
هناك 3000 شخص يعيشون هنا الآن
مع وصول المزيد كل يوم تقريبًا
كل شخص في هذا المخيم من  كانت
بلدة ألين وخط ماسا
حوالي 75٪ كردي الآن على الرغم من إخبارنا
أنه لم يتبق سوى عدد قليل من
الأكراد والناس هنا يعتقدون أن
الهدف النهائي من هذا الهجوم التركي
هو بشكل أساسي دفع الأكراد للخروج من
هذه المنطقة تمامًا وتغيير
التركيبة العرقية لها إلى الأبد
، ولم تفعل تركيا شيئًا يذكر للتخفيف
من مخاوفهم حيث انسحب الأكراد
من هذه المناطق حيث تم نقل العرب بالحافلات إلى
اللاجئين السوريين الذين  تزعم السلطات التركية
أنها في الأصل من هذه المناطق
بعد أكثر من ثماني سنوات من الحرب الأهلية ،
هذا الجزء من سوريا مليء بقصص
النازحين قسراً في
قرية توم نيلسون المسيحية ، وجدنا
المزيد من العائلات من الوصفة
تحتمي في أنقاض كنيسة مدمرة
هل ستحاول العودة إلى المنزل ، لقد سألت
هؤلاء النساء أنه لا يوجد منزل للذهاب إلى
جارتي مسرحية قامت إيزيس بتطهير هذه المنطقة من
المسيحيين عندما كانت تحت السيطرة
ولم يعودوا بعد الآن
توفر القرية ملاذًا لأشخاص آخرين
أجبروا على ترك منازلهم دون أي معنى  من
عودة محتملة